σας βλέπω έχέται κοντά το κίνητό σας οι μαθητές γιατί να μην το έχουν κυριμφαίνεται
από όλες τις έρευνες ότι τρο να το έχουν μαζί τους ενεργοποιημένω τους αποσπάτι προσοχή
και στο διάλημμα τα από μονώνει τα παιδιά για τα αποξενώνει μεγαλύτερι δυσκολία της αυνάσ
μη χαηλίδου στον ενάμησυγχρόνο παντιμετωπισης στη πουργείο παιδία ς πτιδεν είναι οι άνθρωποή δεν είναι
οι συνεργασίες μού οι μεγαλύτερι δυσκολία είναι ένα αντιμετοπίσεις ανθρώπους που θα έπρεπε να γνωρίζουν
και να είναι διαβασμένοι και δεν είναι έχουμε φτάσεις ε ένα σημείω που χρειάζεται να
πάμε προς τα βάνω το αξίζουν τα παιδιά μας θαρά του τύχημα μου είναι να
αλλάξω ταν αλητικά προγράμματα να τα επικαιροποιήσουμε όπως λέμε υπάρχουν τεράστηριες προκλήσεις και αυτές είναι
κυρίως οη αντίσταση στην αλλάγή α βωτήσο μια καταγγεία από έφτασην κοντά σας οι οποία
συγκλώνησε την υπουρο παίας και μου εσυνέβηκε δυστυχώς δε θα το ξεχάσω ποτέ ήταν είνα
παιδάκινι πιαγωγείου δεν το φοβάμε εγώ των αννασχημάτισμο δηλαδή είναι δικαίωμα του προέδρου ί με
εδώ για να συγκεκριμένο χρονικό διάστημα γιαμέ ένα νοαθελιτισμός είναι η γιήσ βασχόληση που θα
αφήσει μακριά τα παιδιά από άλλου ίδου εθυσμούς μην αφήσεται κανένα να σαστερήσει τα όνιρα
σας όσο φιλόδοξα και ανφαίνονται ο αναρκούγονται και κυνηγίστετα λες διατιλί λλοτεν αλλά εροτικά σήμερα
μαζί σς και εδώ μαζί μας στο πλάτο οι υπουργός παιδίας κυρια θνάμχαελίδου και α
μεχαλίδε σε σχτό ευχαριστόπου αποδεκτικάτετην προσκλη εγώ ευχαριστώ για την πρόσκληση σαςσας βλέπω έχεται κοντά
το κίνητό σας οι μαθητές γιατί να μην το έχουν κυριαμιχτο έχουν κοντά τους αλλά
πενεργοποιημένον την ώρα αντομ αθήματος όπως το έχω και εγώ τώρα την ρα της συνδιάλεξης
μα τις υνομιλίας μα είναι συμαντικό να εμπιστευτούμε τα παιδιά μπορούν να το έχουν στη
τσάντα του σε μια θυρίδα για ώρα ανάγκη